this was mine an amazing game I was a  child I always wondering what happened  to those people at war this work minders  showed us the true face reward in this  war of mine you can experience the many  fates of affected victims in war  we really feel the true meaning of being  in war this world - game I love playing  because it sets me in a vulnerable  position that forces me to make hard  choices it's not about surviving it's  about how we survive will you remain a  human or you become an enemy again that  will change the perspective and make  appreciate that you live in a peaceful  country this forum is one of the best  video games that I have played  you  you